hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
can you believe it after all this time
Resident Evil 2 remake is finally here
and I thought we play it together
be warned I'm the biggest scaredy-cat
you will ever meet so expect a lot of
ridiculous noises to come out of my
mouth
one of the main things to note about
this is how dark it is so if you're
watching on mobile phone tablet or even
a laptop to some degree you may need to
boost your brightness all the way up and
to really gain to it turn the lights off
I dare you I'm doing the same I'm
already scared half to death
so if you ready let's do this oh for our
first play for it we have to be Liam
don't we we have to be Leon started
staggering you know I think you drunk
okay tell us be honest now how many
drinks did you have no man I barely had
a buzz on oh come on look just listen
all right she got closer and I got a
good look at her eyes her nose
sounds like my wife I've never seen
anything like it I haven't been able to
sleep she said look calm down buddy calm
down just hey you gotta stay strong okay
don't give in to figure out there right
just getting good
oh I'm so excited
look out in the road man holy [ __ ] I
[Applause]
think she might be dead
uh Undead
whoa wasn't expecting him to have no
hair
[Music]
Godley on listening to his angsty
teenage music is like an aged zac efron
no one's around
some things happened that's weird
and the nightmare begins
hi DeLeon let's do this explore your
surroundings yep look around with the
right stick all good smell very
sensitive
it's good selling wine al all anybody
home hello anybody there my almost good
right
instantly much much scarier
bloody lights something's not right
okay we can run we'll look around you
all right
Hey Dude what's wrong man talk to us
don't move I'll be back for you well
that's ominous listen will you do
anything else you're going to send it to
a zombie okay we'll come back and kill
you later
stop moving officer you need help stay
back sir I got this
Oh
god that looks good freeze well we've
got a weapon let's try this out so one
bullet to the face there's nothing to
does nothing three does nothing for does
put them down and the way we check if a
zombie is dead well we already know how
to check up a zombies dead we shoot them
in the groin
hey he's dead no he's not dead dead now
let's check one more time oh blues leg
off now we can't we're out of bullets
and we're only ten seconds into playing
this is going to be easy okay where we
guards we've got a key whoa but more
importantly we have very important
historical images to look at very
important what we're doing again
oh yeah Resident Evil we have eight
slots
[Music]
can't read that oh I'm so hungry
[Applause]
I'm regretting wasting my bullets now
okay so we just use a ducky then yeah
okay I got it I got it
easy enough
please don't be an ism we have no
bullets we have no bullets what are we
gonna know I already regret right
someone can play this game the zero
bullet run I've been really impressed
I've got a bullets bullets now I've got
four it's done it's fine magic gun hey
Claire alright yeah I think so Thanks
you can thank me later when we're safe
I hope you come on
hold on
[Applause]
let's go to Raccoon City I don't know
hopefully they'll have some answers at
the police station wait you're a cop
yeah Leon Kennedy you are Claire
Redfield I'm looking for my brother
he's a cop to live around here no it's a
good thing we found each other
I don't know what to expect anymore
welcome to Raccoon City hope
look like The Walking Dead
[Music]
[Music]
yeah definitely inspired by the walking
dead a child
Resident Evil
- attention all citizens due to the
citywide outbreak
[Music]
god this is so unreal
police stations not much farther they'll
know something
yeah but what if we're the only ones if
there's no survivors they're survivors
it's a big city there has to be
looks like we're walking from here
[Applause]
more like running yeah good call
[Music]
he's tuning or [ __ ] check it out
you know now
hold on
everybody okay everyone all right
what are those back at it again with the
white vans earlier notions
he's fine he's Leon Kennedy Claire
Claire are you okay
less debt
can't stay here it's not safe I'll be
there
no bullet can sink it's like we're done
okay
my way this way
don't wake up don't wake up don't wake
up they've altered
the graffiti whoa what does that say
another load times check we got a
runaway there it is the station that's
the coffee shop that way
that way here we go
my medians go a day about your business
complete but us
[Applause]
we made its end of the game thanks for
watching it's like a really cool boy
band look at him he's the lead singer
see instinctively I want to go and look
for Easter eggs straight away whatever
the heck that is but I will do my best
to just stick with the story I'll go
Easter egg excuse me I'll go Easter egg
hunting after we've got through this
welcome to the copshop
explore your surrounding hello is
anybody here bullets man I've needed you
for a long time
and we have both this video there has to
be someone here
not good I'm good
I gotta find that guy well something odd
samurai edge I really want to use it but
no we are playing the standard first
time through right what is there to find
can we go through here oh we're going to
need a knife to cut this like in
Resident Evil 7 and it looks like this
is our puzzle three circle things in
loving memory of those who serve read it
later not Easter icon - oh I will need
this in abundance keep out and of course
there's no electric hurry oh damn okay
okay
blood blood man this is dark
you got this Leon so we are looking for
a few sounds the sounds you have a cold
drink before we go you got this you got
dis Leon hello please don't bite me
you've had an accident by the looks of
it love don't find me don't bite me go
buy me go buy me don't buy me thank you
I appreciate that it's a nice switch
Hey look come on this is a herb isn't it
an herb can we eat that plant just all
potted plants we can eat that's the
rules of resident evil right go on shift
it darling
okay I've got to hold it do with that
grip there you go there you go well done
Zac Ephron good Tammy Adam behind dawn
on the one we have a zombie no we don't
the plumbing needs fixing behind door
number two Oh another first aid spray
yes please and thank you anything in
this one maybe a floater no quite clean
quite clean in this precinct no floaters
anywhere sorry I kept back to the real
game I'm doing it again just looking at
random stuff all the time looking for
floaters playing Resident Evil 2 please
don't wake up Jesus please don't wake up
okay come in we're coming dude we come
we got you okay got you
please okay
it'll be fine don't worry - homie
playing football for a while hey your
little black book now it's my little
black book way out three three pendants
from these three statue things and then
we get out okay
easy enough you know jump scare any jump
scares I'm actually prepared for a jump
scare right now come on bring it on
you'll never get to me from my desk
Katie Kim L / desk so you can go up okay
okay we're going we're leaving we're
running away oh gosh we're running away
can I go here no of course not
it's a massive block around the door
just run just run run oh no no no this
way no this is a dead end room maybe
they won't notice I'm here this side in
the corner got away with this
under the dolls other dolls do open one
too right I'll eat them this way and
then run round the opah three of them on
okay the one by the door is going to be
an issue
let's go down down into oh gods gosh
gosh gosh gosh gosh gosh gosh good go
down down down down
if I push this into the other one no
tell me a shot just leave
dead-end come on please please anyone
please please did we pick it no no no we
didn't get that yet
just get out yep get out we're giving
this quicker than this please please
down quicker than this this is not good
for my heart God's sake man
he's true
yeah boy
Marvin is safe magic Marvin my team
Marvelous Marvin Marvin Branagh I know
you are marvel Leon Kennedy there was
another officer I could yeah it'd be
you're not bloody yeah bloody I'm sure
you did what you could Leon has anyone
else started this not a clue who will
get you honestly all you need to know is
that this place will eat you alive if
you aren't careful you know I'm supposed
to start last week and I got a call a
stay away I wish I'd come here sooner
you're here now Leon that's all that
matters
[Applause]
ok lieutenant I'm ready hopefully we'll
be able to find a way out of this
station bet officer you met earlier
Elliott he thought this secret
passageway might do the trick
hmm this is good news we can get you to
a hospital
no no I am not the priority here
lieutenant I'm not just gonna leave you
here I'm giving you an order
rookie you save yourself first I'd come
with you but I just know you down now
you'll need this I can't take stop I
kiss it oh it's a knife and don't make
my mistake if you see one of those
things uniform or not you do not
hesitate do to be bitten by two so far
I'm fine or you run got it
it must be Ellie from The Last of Us I'm
in dude
uh-huh combat knife look at that that's
not a knife that's a knife l want
already it r2 to slash it can be used to
counter-attack with l1 find three
medallions Marvin are you gonna be okay
well I find three medallions I can't
stop him
won't let me stop ahh god damn it game
knows I want to stab him sit closer
the stabbing you're lucky this time
Marvin right first one is easy there's a
lion statue we need a head flower bird
boom one down two to go
peace epistle instantly nervous when I
opened doors that guy's gonna move no
it's legit dead what the hell is shuttle
scared the bejesus out of me everything
scares the bejesus out of me
don't you dare wake up
you okay Derek
now it's not feeling to cracking huh
who's wrecking soda okay guy but this
mouth on the pipe don't drop don't drop
don't drop don't drop please don't fall
on me please don't [ __ ] oh yeah
okay I'm a manly man
Oh anything club cake whoo my heart is
absolutely killing any boards no yet not
yet
Gatecrasher
she's tucked back to the neck no recoil
in the slightest by extra nose 9i oh now
that is how you fall check if she's dead
she's dead kid not that she'd not dead
stop shooting him in the groin shooting
the mean grind gives them extra health
for something record of evidence and I
look for green words if there's no words
we just take them on map that's good
that's good
operations room and we need to do so red
rooms mean we haven't finished what's
inside blue rooms mean we've done
everything possible this CLO why is this
more nerve-wracking you're gonna wake up
you're gonna know I'm here as he figured
out already uses of gunpowder
yeah combo yeah I get it cumberland
combine them together doing bullets
we're at Leon's welcome we've got to the
other side oh wow in the original game
there was two elves on the word welcome
so you see there's a space that it looks
like the fixed it for this second
version that used to say welcomed Leon
first assignment your mission is to
unlock your desk the key to your success
is the initials in our first names put
the letters in order of our desks two
looks make sure you get both okay so my
desk is locked scrolled in the corner
and blood big glad you're not here
rookie I am now so there's two locks
here leave me alone
so we're looking for nameplates there's
one M Marvin I'm gonna have to put it
down we we can't risk it even for a
chocolate biscuit master get out and
bouncer thank you
right second desk he's gonna wake up
Rita ah Rita from zero outbreak file to
something that's off get down get down
get down you haven't see where you going
right he's done so last name plate is on
the floor which is George G R M o m RG
rava mg1 down cooking on gas next side
is d4 David then it's efore Elliot MOS
the other one there is an N
No d-ohh it's up in reverse order okay
it's okay okay I get there it just takes
me a bit of time to figure stuff out but
I do get there good old Ned sort it and
we get an extended clip lianas Kennedy
Matilda is looking ma'am fine what's
this look at the external the extra L
from welcome Wow nineteen ninety-eight
that is a really good call back Easter
egg but I promise we're not looking for
Easter eggs I will stop at some point
yeah it's the guy in the office in the
brain box
we still find and down he goes it does
it really does so one thing to remember
about the zombie apocalypse shooting
zombies in the penis brings them back to
on life on dead life man loss graphics
hunting who do you feel tense all the
time it's gonna be a struggle to old Joe
Joe's locker it's gonna be a struggle to
go to sleep tonight
let's get busted oh my god Ricky scared
the life out of me breathe breathe I
don't pass out don't you dare wake up as
well
now I got me anyway how feisty here the
size of him
freight train this is not going well
it's getting it down door please maybe
we need to change tactics maybe it's
about getting the legs in school so then
he's stuck on the floor now what was
that noise
well it's you know we can leave him
there how does he get every time he
deserves it on sequel the hell was that
noise what the hell is that I'm very
nervous right now I'm trying to stay
boil I'm trying to stay uplifting yeah
let's do a puzzle instead stories memo
spare keys and knock it right ok 1 or 2
has bullet Jew said but what are six can
tell one of three and nine oh do oh no
of course we need to find the key right
ok I understand when divine the keys
a roll of film I wonder if it has
pictures of Rebecca chambers on it again
it was very questionable back then get
some more bullets thank God
oh ouch two or three we haven't got two
of those keys 208 shotgun shells oh I
can't wait to find the shotgun and
there's a shotgun so we need to pass
okay we know what we need next that's
fine oh my god just died
what for God's sake you piece of turds
did die die die it just it's just worth
20 bullets oh my heart all right you got
your own dance troupe
you can be taken up tap-dance out there
is this a mime jazz number we got bars
for him afterwards afterwards afterwards
so these are the boards that we can
sorry well this Dave your dancing was
fantastic but I'm putting my sugar check
on you later fella
viki's what's upstairs are you freakin
zombie yeah you know trick me lock I
make really manly noises let's go you
see he's down how strong your legs there
we go how do we get busted now we put
more bullets into them than you can ever
imagine
you can live love you look good steam
room oh good [ __ ] oh yeah I wonder
what you're gonna do
well let me preempt you okay legit dead
still scared me
[Music]
what is that on the wall thank you very
much
so there's the statue that we need and
this c4 c4 so we're going to need a
detonator aren't we yeah let's find a
detonator
some guy scribbling detonate big green
lettuce yes
detonator we need your own new pouch to
that 10 slots now cooking on gas well
we're back for you soon lady I don't do
this I don't want to do this please be
dead please be dead yes I'm a manly man
I need you back here ASAP
are you okay Marvin what's up Marv I've
got something to show you
it's important copy that I'll be right
there on my way bro
so there's one guarding there there's a
couple eating each other it's lovely
another one is the one with the stairs
horse before we go down stairs let's
check out the very nothing happens
nothing happened
don't wake up don't wake up don't wake
up thank you
nope not being that we're going here Hey
look statue get in stumbled across that
one and we got the new map right I'm
ready dude yeah
Oh fantastic he's dead and his legs are
crushed what what what he's like the
traps no they know that his legs are one
with the dog not anymore
get you shots get your shots I need to
learn to wait for the reticle to be
ready to be shot so it cancels out the
bloom okay so we need a detonator we
need to figure out what the heck this
statue needs a scorpion okay fish thing
scorpion next yes lucky
I completely forgot the last one unicorn
medallion salted mate already completed
Marvin Marvin you still going strong bud
it's a real champion our Marvin how's it
going dude deleting your search history
I don't want to look at camera I knew
she'd make it you know her
yeah she's Claire Claire I came into
town with her you can get to that
courtyard through the second floor East
Side I'm on it thanks lieutenant
second floor Eastside let's just quickly
put this in here so we don't have to
carry it around Oh an amazing yeah but
the passage isn't open yet so many more
doors to unlock now this is just alright
so this just makes it less of and
labyrinth so you're not stuck traveling
around the old building
I see point five hey I just have you you
barricaded the door man I'm impressed
say you're half dead I'm very impressed
let's put the other medallion in and
then we'll crack on lion medallion just
one more to go Marvin get hyped so
onwards and upwards we go so yeah it's a
really strange how the reticle works has
blip this sort of like bloom put into
this game if I aim here watch the
reticle it takes a second to zoom in to
be actually accurate so yeah it can't be
frustrating but it's all good the Spade
door we got a speed door key men let's
go inside so we can throw it away but I
remember being a child and knowing never
to throw to discard items away but I'm
sure our chocolate noise
Oh that'll be the helicopter let's have
a look-see oh we can't have a look-see
I'll drop these boards it looks like we
need a crank or some some winch you need
to crank that Soulja Boy casting a knife
in it okay okay what's in here statue
missing an arm here's your arm sir
barb if we look at it this isn't gonna
work
it's clasping something so it's holding
something so we have to find something
for it to hold Oh lovely that's the key
card to get the shotgun things are going
well for us now and some light reading
if you're into that kind of thing I
skimmed it so much to do with so little
time waiting room that's where I came
from
exit Claire we're coming for you Claire
although Clara whew don't mind us want
to see this a helicopter crash first
yeah Wow anything to pick up no let's go
see Claire it's like I still alive
Claire is this your fault
have you been flushing at the pilot
Claire hold on I'll be right there okay
Metro Fire yeah let you go buyout Claire
it's so nice to see you how are you
doing yes smooth isn't me I'm in one
piece
unfortunately no but how are you doing
oh you doing just surviving my word the
both very flirty yeah any luck with your
brother no not yet clear don't lose hope
I'm sure we're gonna find him
yeah definitely not going that way you
know what that means yeah ginger time
there I think you should go don't worry
about me Leon you take care of your
stuff you need to go now okay let's get
through this both of us
demonstrate love so on her playthrough
she'll have to get through all that
Marvin situation here Marvin do you copy
Marvin damn it Marvin resting here son
don't think they're coming in
no sure hey that was a lovely little
flip you did there
should i box it up I'll just run away oh
damn son I am buddy in here
don't waste it don't waste the bullets
alright here's the door let's cook this
off and see where it leads come on
I'm they already been here you're bored
you up you can stay outside
Oh flashbang and we can fit it anywhere
great
we are not waking up anytime soon
gun powder
yes oh he's outside
it's the big lock from earlier hey damn
it
is this all this everything I need is in
this room trout so I don't believe them
damn it damn it damn it down I love how
they fall legit groin shot didn't wake
one up okay right we get back through
run away a little bit
I so loud are you good sleep no he's up
again the man is a rock which where am I
going
so that's where I need to bring it I
have space now
told me run round the entire table
[Music]
I'm back to safety right we still need a
detonator still alive stick with it
mouth
you're my hair Rob remember so just one
more to go need to detonate won't you
put a detonator I can't think of any way
boy oh no sorry
Oh wake up me quickly make a touchback
and grab the shotgun before we go any
further forward Hank just get the
shotgun and we will continue with the
story hello Betsy we do good things
together so we are progressing really
well now if we get through here for the
steam room and I think this should leave
as leader this should lead us to the c4
detonator and then you know I think we
are complete we don't we dust it stay
positive
this is what I like you
it's okay let's just get on with this
well what's happened here everyone is a
bit in pieces
damn Daniel you think to steal to doing
here we're all good
another one right it's blind it doesn't
know where I am is but it doesn't know
where I am my sight was blind
goddamnit no just run run run run can
you come in here okay we're safe in here
oh I thought liquors were completely
blind
I'm sorry not blind yeah mind and I'm
deaf oh that's right they are blind so
how did it know where I was so this is
Chris Redfield desk gotta love that made
in heaven jacket and there's Rebecca's
desk and if I remember rightly she
always leaves a canister a first aid
with her man there's loads of stuff
we've got you well if you weren't a
battery for a detonator where would you
oh look
I think I got it see I don't know if
we're looking for a simple double a
battery or some sort of car battery but
it's something for a detonator
no way well you see then combined there
we go
Wow okay that literally took about five
seconds thoughts
Heckscher one day hey there's a picture
we looked at earlier it's the Stars team
special tactics and Rescue Service memo
left nine right 15 left 7 9 15 7 9 15 7
remember 9 15 7 Oh
915 seven is it in your skull yet 915
seven think we need a USB stick no maybe
not
we're all good oh yes we do we need the
USB stick yes USB port so it's something
nice in there okay we'll come back soon
America darts miracle darts
okay
Leon is ready to complete this verse
mission where is it where is it where is
it where is it where is it where is it
where is it where is it
oh man I'm scared
it's now on the roof slowlyslowly
catchee monkey slowly slowly
oh god I am so nervous right now
herbs oh just stay still stay still stay
still stay still stay still stay still
don't make a sound don't make us out
please [ __ ] off please go away
Shama shove this shotgun him in the
skull well in their brain box yeah whoa
run away didn't know where I am doesn't
know where I am it knows where I am it
does REM no no no no no no no just just
go crazy just go crazy just go crazy
please run out please for now please run
out yes
your life has expired those damn nervous
next time I'm on edge alright we have
the detonator we have the bloody battery
to go with it
Zach you may ask you made a funny
thank you man this is getting really
really scary now hey look with brains on
the wall insta fire here we go let's see
the bloom she's fine
she's not fine right the liquors by a
long way the most scary thing in this
game so far oh we need a jack ah I run
towards flowers now thinking that their
health herbs who's the guy in the roof
again here this means we're in the right
place there it is let's blow this up
farouq farouq farouq is on fire what's
the blast radius do you think just think
about right here should I hide a little
bit yeah
yep everyone heard that great bloody
great smashing super fantastic right
there it is
face arrow like a snaky thing we're
doing well
was there a liqueur there just zombies
got a good read about it
oh I'm so nervous oh my heart feels like
it's gonna be out of my chest
staying calm where is it
so it's behind me it's behind me it's
behind me just keep it that's not the
right way
keep running keep running keep running
just do not stop Leon do not stop okay
relax relax okay easy easy that I could
have fallen asleep it with that simple
look locker-room c.a.p
remember that remember that you still
remember in 915 seven for the other
locker
yeah so across the hall down into West
office into the back up there 915 seven
what's in the box okay okay two more
slots yep I'll take that twelve slots
now we do more really well where they
will it Whaley rail you know what I
think we've done it our first puzzle
this is the end don't underst it
so we've done it episode 1 that must be
a closed for episode 1 I really enjoyed
that that was fantastic
don't leave Marv behind so it goes
underground that's it that's our way out
lieutenant Branagh Marvin it's time to
go we need to get you to a hospital
right now
Marvin's changing save yourself
come on I've got you oh look we can
still make it out of here together just
it's too late
I tried Leon but I couldn't stop it
we can't let this thing spread it's on
you now
just go
right in the fields I understand
see you Marvin my brother from another
mother okay so we're gonna leave it
there
so that's episode one done and dusted
I'll be back again tomorrow if you fancy
joining me I won't let you down Marvin
I'll likely cut them down a bit more in
future this one I've tried to let it
play out as much as possible so in
future there'll be a little bit shorter
anyway
I imagine from PlayStation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you tomorrow